you've made it to the finals did you
ever dream the day would come well I
think it was only a dream I mean yeah I
dreamed it but I didn't think it was
like reality also dream of riding a big
purple dinosaur with wing that is what I
gonna yeah so yeah we're here I feel
like we're representing the people that
watch the show because we're definitely
not people did it the good dancers you
know I think you think we were put here
because the people voted for us I think
I think I am the people I said that
tonight on show like I am them and they
are me and I think that you just help
your friends and I hope that's what
we're all feeling Shauna you looked
genuinely shocked what was that about
this is about us going sure what was my
face I was like I was trying to
understand what was going on and then
everyone screamed so much and I was like
wait
are they safe or they don't do are we
going home we I don't know what's going
on someone tell me what's going on I
just genuinely I didn't know whether we
were gonna go through or not and then it
was very unclear what was happen was
saying if I couldn't hear it and so I
didn't know if the three left on stage
we're going home or if the three that
were named we're going home and I was
very planned for the Freestyle for the
finale numbers what are you doing we
have a Regents which is gonna be at cha
cha MC Hammer but I'm gonna make it
bigger and better and just embellish on
it more but also put a little more but
then we have the freestyle and the
Freestyle is gonna be amazing I'm gonna
build it around you know if I'll be his
personality and he's journey on the show
after we did loose freestyle is my jam
though this is where like I excel and
thrive is during a freestyle where I've
creative control and freedom so watch
fitting raps but last question how did
you manage to keep this t-shirt as
secrets we never showed it to anybody we
didn't show in dress rehearsal when I
put it on and put it on in my trailer
and put the other shirt on over it it
was uh it was very it was a very secret
secret because we wanted that winner but
she would she was like what's happening
no idea no I had no idea that he was
gonna do this I thought he might rip his
shirt open at the end for like you know
like rip your shirt open like we do
sometimes have lens face on a t-shirt
how long have you been planning this
oh do you know you wanted to do well
might as soon as we had Lynn as the
judge we wanted to dedicate it to Lynn I
wanted to be all in like I wanted
Evelyn's underwear I figured that'd be
too much I favor - I wanna go like boom
boom but then I thought no even I have a
limit so yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]